so we begin today with perhaps the most
important news story of our time this is
an urgent controversy one which demands
our full attention the question at issue
is this who was the first man to wear a
dress was it billy porter or harry
styles that's what we find ourselves
debating today uh and i think for good
reason you know i can't imagine any
subject more salient more paramount than
this you may remember about a year ago
when the pop star harry styles appeared
on the cover of vogue dressed like a
nine-year-old girl who just raided her
grandmother's closet and this was we
were informed at the time
a historic moment i mean a man in a
dress what courage what innovation
previous generations won world wars and
they invented space travel
we put our male pop stars in dresses
that is our contribution to the
historical conversation and what a
contribution it is
when all when you know when it was all
said and done of course most of us
thought that the story was over harry
styles had worn address
peace and harmony had been established
across the globe mankind had reached its
zenith
utopia was upon us
or so we thought
little did we know that things were far
more complicated there was a darker side
to harry's blouse
there were skeletons in the closet
or perhaps out of the closet in this
case
as has been reported uh this morning by
cnn buzzfeed yahoo news
the daily beast los angeles times tmz
many of our nations other most
prestigious publications billy porter
has emerged all these months later
to talk about the pain and trauma that
harry styles his skirts have caused him
now porter is an actor i think honestly
i'm not exactly sure what he actually
does for a living or why anybody knows
his name as far as i can tell his
primary occupation is to dress in tacky
pant suits
and attend award shows somehow he's
found a way to monetize that hobby of
his more power to him i suppose and he's
not happy that harry styles is stealing
his his cross-dressing drag queen
thunder
from the cnn report it says in an
interview with british paper the sunday
times porter argued that there was a
disconnect and the opportunities
afforded to him as a black gay man and
those given to styles quote i feel like
the fashion industry has accepted me
because they have to he said i created
the conversation about non-binary
fashion and yet vogue still puts harry
styles a straight white man in a dress
on the cover for their for their first
uh for the first time
i was the first one doing it and now
everybody's doing it i'm not dragging
harry styles but he doesn't care he's
just doing it because it's the thing to
do
this is politics for me this is my life
i had to fight my entire life to get to
the place where i could wear a dress to
the oscars
all stiles has to do is be white and
straight
then he later on went on to say i
changed the whole game i personally
changed the whole game and that's not
ego that's just a fact
this is he's fought his whole life
this is the this is this is it this is
the achievement of his life
is to wear a dress to the oscars
and it's not ego you know uh he wants to
be sure that we understand not at all
why would we think that a man who cries
to the media because he doesn't get to
be the only guy wearing a dress has an
ego
billy porter's a humble man i mean he's
a man of dignity
a man of
humility prancing on the red carpet in a
ball gown
yeah he's prancing but he's doing it in
a dignified way
but is it true that he invented the
concept of crossdressing well no of
course it's not not remotely this is one
of the many contradictions we run into
with the proponents of gender fluidity
on one hand they insist that you know
nothing they're doing is novel or
unprecedented they assure us that all of
their wildest gender inventions have a
long and storied history
they say that there were you know
trisexual genderqueer sadomasochistic
furries back in george washington's time
maybe he was one himself who knows
traditional cultures throughout the
globe have expansive ideas about gender
they tell us you can hack your way into
the amazon rainforest and stumble across
an uncon uncontacted tribe and no doubt
that tribe will have its own sex
reassignment clinics
this is all quite widespread it's
universal it's in keeping with
historical precedent they say but then
on the other hand
when a man puts on a mini skirt and
winks at a camera they want us to throw
him a parade as if he just landed on the
moon
so all of this stuff is normal and
universal and totally ordinary
and also revolutionary and bold and
unique and daring
all at once
well okay then
and yet
there's something revealing i think
about this controversy if we can call it
that
because we notice again in perhaps you
know the most direct and explicit way
that we've seen yet
how womanhood has been turned into a
trophy to be one
or a flag to be captured
billy porter
other guys like them they they wear
femininity like a halloween costume
it looks ridiculous on him it looks ugly
profane vulgar
he appropriates it he makes a mockery of
it and he demands to be celebrated
now sure anybody can wear a dress that's
precisely why it's no achievement to
wear one
but dresses are designed to accentuate
the female form
if you have no female form to accentuate
at best you'll end up looking silly like
a dog in a sweater worse because you're
ridiculing
and you look worse than that because you
are ridiculing the feminine
even while trying to claim it as your
own
you have turned womanhood into a
performance
into a comedy
a not very funny one
more of a farce a tragedy
but there are still more direct ways of
going about that of course like rachel
levine who's the biological male hhs
official who according to an
announcement for the biden
administration this morning
has now been sworn in as a four-star
admiral admiral making him the u.s
public health services quote first ever
female four-star admiral
that's the official announcement from
the by administration that's in there
that's in their press release
first ever female four-star admiral
is a man
female not even saying woman but female
he's been given not just the social
designation but the biological one as
well womanhood was awarded to him
like the four-star rank
it's a badge that he can wear around on
his chest
like his fake breasts it's just a it's a
it's a fake thing that he can wear
around it's an object
[Music]
that's what these people have made of
womanhood hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated